up
just give me a sec guys i'm connecting
right now up
i'm just turning to my guys on discord
that i'm live
alright guys so
it's asia hours i guess most of you guys
are sleeping but um
it's actually easier for me you know to
just do my videos
uh at this time because it's daytime for
me so
i'm just gonna go through what happened
yesterday uh hey bro hey hey
what's up man
so i'm gonna go um through what happened
yesterday on amc gamestop very important
guys we had two very important days
so i want to go through the price action
i'm gonna go through the option market
as usual to check uh the short interest
what happened there i'll try to explain
uh why this move happened yesterday um
so i'm going to start with amc gamestop
then i want to talk about bgmv
uh bbby and playboy plby and then guys
i'm gonna answer all of your questions
so turn volume up please okay
i have some issues with this volume guys
to be honest because okay let me put it
stronger
okay
all right
okay guys so i put the volume uh higher
i hope you hear me better i'm gonna try
just to you know stay close to the mic
and it should be good
all right yeah i love you too love you
too bro
okay guys so let's start let's start
with amc
it's a lot of things to say
so as usual guys uh i'm gonna much
better awesome bro cool thanks for
telling me
um all right so amc
we had a very nice move up especially at
the open so i hope you guys see my
screen
good enough
um
as you guys know we have a resistance at
44.
so basically this is the recent high and
it is also
the intersect with the downward sloping
trendline that i get by connecting the
highs in a log scale and whenever we
have some intersects like this it's a
bit unexplained to me but very often the
market likes to go through it or at
least touch it and here it's a nice
example because i'm having those trend
lines for i don't know maybe two or
three weeks and very surprisingly amc
went to 44 and got rejected
so what is the situation now the
situation is still good because we came
back in this triangle which was very
important for me we needed to stay there
i didn't like this fake out like i
explained before
we ran up to 44 got rejected but we came
from the lows so whenever you come from
the lows and you arrive on the
resistance it's totally fine to get
rejected the first time but for the move
to stay strong what we need to see
is um
is a price action that stays as close as
possible to the stream line all right so
this is what i want to see right now
for the buddhist case to be still there
um we can also analyze try to see where
are the support levels that we get here
so for now we didn't have the breakout
i'm gonna analyze of course the
situation um if we do have this breakout
i'm gonna tell you what i think would
happen but for now we don't have it so
let's assume discounting is correct so
in this counting you guys know that i
like to use elliott wave theory and that
this method is actually uh working very
well even on stocks like amc the reason
behind is that this method is working
well whenever uh there is a lot of
emotions involved amongst investors and
in this kind of stock guys you know that
emotions are here for everyone so this
is the reason why eliot theory is
working quite well and what i'm seeing
here is an abcde
all right
triangle that is typically a pattern
that is forming uh in false waves so if
this is correct then this is a one right
and this is the beginning of
a new move so this is a one
so we're expecting to have a two and
then three four five and as usual guys
whenever let me put this a bit higher
all right
usually third waves are the waves that
like to go through those important
levels so here uh the important
resistances that i identify here are 44
and 52 so it would make sense to me that
we have a second wave pullback that is
you know a bit rejected here and then
that we have a massive third wave that
just go through this uh entire uh area
of resistance
so let me just change the degree it's a
minor wave and you guys know i want to
show you that again because you're gonna
see where i want to bring you right now
bam you know you can find this book uh
on the internet very easily so it's the
pdf of the eliot wave theory you just
type elliott wave principle sorry it's
not this one so this is the book but i'm
going for the pdf so where is the pdf
is it here it's here all right the pdf
is here
okay just give me a sec
and what i want to show you you go to
the page 78
all right and here
i think i've already showed you that but
uh this is the typical retracement
levels that we have whenever we have an
impulse so five waves up uh five was
five waves up and second waves usually
they go to the 61.8 retracement uh it
can also be 38.2 it can also be 50 but
usually it's 61.8 so
here on amc what we have is that this is
it's supposed to be a first wave so we
can expect a pullback to the 61.8
percent retracement of this move up all
right so if
you guys for example want to get in or
if i would like to increase my position
this is the level i would be targeting
so you can see that here this level is
uh around 38.2
and it's also exactly where we have the
50 period moving average that was acting
in the past you know here as a
resistance
it was not a perfect um
moving average to use for support and
resistance but it's still there so we
have a double reason to think that 38.2
is a very strong support so i think that
as long as we stay above that level uh
we're looking great it's just a second
wave pullback and then we are expecting
the third wave to come
now guys you know that we have earnings
coming soon
so
i
checked this on bloomberg i think it's
pretty interesting to um
sorry bam
okay give me a sec i lost my bloomberg
all right so we have earnings as you can
see here coming on the um
8th of november all right third quarter
earnings expectations are around minus
0.53 so still negative earnings you guys
can see that the expectation for the
next year
are
almost coming to zero but we still
expect amc to um
to lose money for now but you can see
that this is growing quite fast actually
so this is the reason why
we have that bullishness and what we
want to see is um earnings actually
beating expectations because just like
we had on the 9th of august we had
earnings expected at minus 93
and we had
an announcement of minus 0.7 so we
beated the earnings expectations by 24
percent so this is what we would like to
see
uh here as well and if we beat
expectation on the 8th of november guys
it's funny but it would be exactly where
the second wave pullback could be and
this could be the catalyzer that brings
us to
um
higher levels and especially to break
this
upper band of this triangle all right so
now let's assume this happens
so we come back here we already came
back here so we basically stay a bit in
this area we can also just go right away
uh higher it's possible as well
uh and then i think that we would have a
one two three four five going to very
high levels then coming back and then
going to the target that you guys know
that is around
130 this is my target that i get using
always the same thing guys all right
using this
uh it's just assuming that the fifth
wave is extended and whenever the fifth
wave is extended it's usually equal to
one point six one eight times one plus
three as we can see here guys
all right it's this situation
are right here in this situation the
fifth wave so this is elliot with theory
the fifth wave whenever it is extended
is equal to 1.618 times one plus three
so you've seen probably me doing that
many times but i think it's still
important to do it again guys not to
forget
what is the target and we might of
course go higher but this is a target
that i think we should reach
for this fifth wave maybe we can go
higher but at least there so if i do
that
bam and apply to the bottom of the force
wave i have
135 so this is my target roughly for i
don't know maybe if the breakouts
happens this week or next week it would
probably be
around jan 22.
okay i'm checking quickly if you have
some questions amc and jimmy charts were
almost identical today
um
not really actually not really and i'm
gonna show you why but jimmy is one step
ahead actually
uh but let me finish on amc
hey yo man
what's up bro
exactly yes i want to tell you man
exactly yes so um
let's go on uh let's check guys what we
have on the synthetic short
because you guys know that it's very
important i'll show you i showed you
that already yesterday
but let's quickly analyze that again
okay bam amc
bam refreshing all right
bam
so here we go
so as you guys can see we have a dtc
that is equal to three right now um
and it was rather around two before so
we have an increase of 50 percent of uh
the dtc we have this huge gamma on the
145 strike uh before that the gamma is
located in right around 40 so this is
the reason why yesterday we had this
strong move whenever you have a big
amount of options like we do here you
can see on this chart guys the 40 strike
up let me just come back to your
questions
the fully strike is the strike where you
have the most options uh if i don't take
into account 145 which is just
absolutely massive but just on the um
on the fully strike we have the biggest
number of options so let's check where
this is coming from because this is the
kind of information that is interesting
to use
to know whenever a strong move could
happen
and the answer is whatever we go through
a strike where we have a big amount of
options
and especially if those options are
coming from a short maturity so here the
40 strike you you have 6 million
equivalent shares
and we can check where this is coming
from
and it's mostly coming from the gen 22
so it would have been even uh stronger
if it was coming from november or
december but this is the reason why when
we go through this kind of strikes so 40
is yesterday guys i remind you that we
open with the gap up through the 4d
level and that's why we had this
continuation on the upside it's probably
option market makers that were buying
like crazy and their best just got us
rejected here let me go back to the
synthetic short interest
okay sorry
okay
and nothing much else to say apart of
the fact that this is still very unusual
for any stock i'm going to show you
other stocks very soon
to have this massive number of options
here it's very unusual and this is the
reason why for example if we go strongly
through 145
guys this would be you know we would
probably
uh just go to 180 or 200 right away
so
so this needs to be taken into account
if we get closer to this level but if we
only go 230 for example
this unfortunately would not create this
um
move amplification that we see whenever
we go through these strikes
all right
so i'm almost done yeah give me some
likes guys i have only 15 likes like
come on smash that like button give me
some likes
and
and i'm checking if you have some
questions
exactly to tell yes my man yeah bro
okay so i'm almost done for amc
i'm just gonna
what else can i tell you here guys uh
what i can tell you is that it's looking
very good you know it's just
for me um this is just the confirmation
that the move is the movement i mean the
apes community movement is still on and
that
uh and that we will just see this strong
moves that i'm talking about yes for i
don't know maybe one year it's been i'm
talking about about amc
and we had this strong move up here
and
i think this the same kind of movement
is coming the same kind of move sorry is
coming so let's see um i'm done on amc
yeah last thing i wanted to tell you
guys is of course whenever we have price
action going higher
and volume going higher it's good you
know it's not
a bullish signal but if we had volumes
going lower on the price action going
higher
this would be a bearish divergence
created with the volumes so this would
be bad but we don't have it we have
volumes going higher price action going
higher just rejected once at the
resistance i mean it's totally fine for
me
and yeah earnings coming on the 8th of
november so i'm done for amc guys i'm
gonna now do gme um and then i'm gonna
start to answer some questions
good morning from germany hey bro what's
up
yeah i do crypto brother i do crypto uh
i do crypto i like ethereum i like
bitcoin of course
i like bnb but i'm not here for now to
talk about crypto so let's do gme all
right guys insane move i mean i was
actually live yesterday during this move
and i needed to stop the life because i
needed to take some positions guys to
you know just uh do my uh trader stuff
it was a very very um important day
this was kind of expected i mean
um
as you guys probably know you know i'm
posting every day uh some updates about
amc and and jamie in the free area of my
discord and i i'm just doing my best you
know to um analyze the price action and
tell you what levels are important to
break above or what we need to see for
the bullish press action to
happen this kind of things and here i
was telling you that above 185
uh we would probably have uh run up to
230 in the week so i was saying that two
or three days ago
um
so that happened all right it's not
always happening but it happened here so
it's interesting to analyze and then
here at 220
we have a strong resistance so uh
someone was just asking me were telling
me amc and gme chat was almost identical
so phil
phil you were telling me that and to me
i agree we both we have triangles on
both charts all right
uh they're not the same size exactly
they're not you know exactly um
done at the same time but they're still
triangles and the difference is that
jimmy just went through the 200 to the
level like a knife through butter it was
just you know bears uh just disappeared
all right there were number bears um
and
so this is very positive all right this
means that
uh bulls won the victory
of the beginning of the day but then
guys um
we got rejected
uh quite strongly and we closed below
so that's not positive all right so we
have very positive signal that we went
through and then a negative signal that
we got rejected and closed unfortunately
below 230. why is it that important guys
it's because
a lot of institutional clients are
actually holding the shares so i can
show you for example for amc this is the
report i just download
downloaded from bloomberg
let me show you that guys it's quite
interesting so this is for amc guys
there is a lot of information you know
it's public information they're just
well sum up you know bloomberg are doing
a quite impressive job but of course
it's not free
um
but i i need that to work so of course i
can share it with you guys and the
information i'm looking for is
just give me a sec
okay i can't find it
okay i don't know where they put it but
it's it was basically
showing who are the biggest investors of
amc and we had those uh you know
vanguard
oh it's here all right so vanguard was
the first one with 8.6 percent uh
blackrock with six percent uh state
street so of course behind those big
institutional clients
we have retail investors all right so
uh this is just showing you that
um the end user might be the end i mean
holder of the share might be a written
investor but the guys that are really
having the positions are big
institutional clients the reason why i'm
bringing that is because those guys
um
they follow technical analysis you know
of course they have some experts you
know guys maybe you know like me one day
i don't know i prefer to help you guys
to be honest but you guys know that i'm
an ex-banker i was working a bank i was
working with this kind of clients um i
was not doing this business exactly but
i know a bit how they work and i can
tell you that they use technical
analysis they use signals they use those
levels to stop plus depositions to
increase the positions and if we have a
close above 231 or 32 on gamestop i can
tell you that those guys who are very
big in amc and gamestop it's roughly the
same investors
um
they would they would push the button
you know they would just buy so it would
bring some uh very nice bullish momentum
so this is the reason why i really want
to see gamestop closing above this level
now what do we have here i think we have
the triangle that is complete all right
before my e-wave is here guys in august
21.
so
um
and right now we are doing one
two and we are in the third wave all
right and i'm having this uh counting
for
uh i don't know two or three months all
right
so
it's not always like that but this
counting is for now very correct almost
perfect and we are in a typical third
wave so this is giving me confidence
that i'm gonna be right about what is
gonna happen next as well
um how do we know it's a third wave guys
it's kind of easy uh
volumes are
explosive the price action is explosive
and we go through very important
resistances so this is the definition of
a third wave
now
uh how high can we expect the third wave
to go and are we still in the in this
third wave so third waves as you guys
know they develop in five waves so let's
zoom in let's try to understand where uh
are we in terms of um
wave counting inside the third wave so i
can already tell you i have a target
around 300 350 for this third wave
happening maybe around in two weeks
maybe something like this so for now we
had first wave second corrective waves
okay
second corrective wave
that was
here so
okay so this four has nothing to do here
the four is there
okay and then here so let's count i
didn't do that uh yet so i'm gonna i'm
gonna do this with you that's why i
think it's cool to be live because you
can see everything i'm doing so it takes
a bit a little bit more time
but i mean i have time i hope you guys
have time too
and and let's do it together all right
so one
two
then here one two three four five this
is a three
we're doing a four so there's a fifth
coming all right there's a fifth coming
uh i guess it's going to be extended
and
is the force wave correction complete so
this is
not a minor wave so let me it's a minuet
wave okay
all right so we have something like this
so this false wave you guys know let's
check let's check all right false wave
where do they go
where do they go guys they go to the
38.2 retracement level usually all right
here okay page 78 79 bam look at that
guys fourth waves they go to 38.2 38.2
of what
will will it stay up there but phil i'm
gonna try to answer the question
i don't think it's gonna stay there it's
either gonna go lower or higher um
but
let me explain
so forth wave they usually go to the
38.2 retracement so let's see what is
the 38.2 retracement of wave 3 because
now we have a third wave all right so
let's measure it
and here we can see that we went
rather to the 50
so
it's a bit deep already for me so
anything
below i would say 205
or two even below so okay we have
another technique so here i'm going to
keep the fibs okay
and for this wave to be a force wave so
for us to know that the fifth wave is
coming we want to see this false wave uh
like we usually have it in the books so
we want it around the 220 level we are
already below so it's not very good but
you guys can see that on the hourly time
frame which is very used by day traders
i personally use it a lot
for training stop loss most of the times
is acting very well as support so i
would say that as long as we stay above
that
okay
above this level that is going higher um
it's looking great so i repeat above
213 roughly i would accept some excess
because there is a lot of volatility i
would accept some access to the 200 or 5
area
so above 205 above 2
okay let's call it 2
14.
we are still in the third wave and we
are expecting a fifth wave uh when right
now right now tomorrow today maybe you
know maybe friday or monday i don't know
but in the coming days we're expecting a
fixed wave how high can this fifth wave
go alright let's be honest
i don't know but i can try to guess so i
have two different methods i can use
here to guess how high this fifth wave
can go
um the first one i'm just gonna apply
the same method as usual guys i'm gonna
assume the fifth serve is extended
and i'm gonna uh apply the ratio one
plus
uh one point six one eight times one
plus three this one all right
so i'm doing that right now with you
guys i haven't done it before so let's
see what we get
hey and you see guys
what what did i say before i said 300
350 and when i apply this meth this
method i actually like to uh use the
one-to-one relation that i see often
happening or the one to 1.618 and what
are those levels they are 300 and 350
funny right
i mean you know this is technical
analysis it's often using different
methods you find the same
levels and the more methods bring you to
the same levels the more trustful are
those levels and here why did i say 350
in the first place guys
bam
easy okay
one high one high so the 350 is the
natural resistance that we're having for
this third wave let me put it in yellow
so this is my take okay
my take is that
uh if we don't
trade below 205
today i mean tonight
tomorrow
uh
and on monday
then
i think that we would go to 350
which means we're gonna have
uh
50 move up all right
let's see let's see to be honest you
know it's kind of even when i do my own
analysis it's kind of you know hard to
believe
but it's the best i can tell you guys
it's really what i what i think i have
of course positions uh on gamestop
uh i can even tell you that yesterday i
hedged a bit my position i bought some
puts around 230 and uh i'm gonna sell it
today around 214 or maybe even lower to
214 205 i'm gonna sell the protection i
bought and i'm just gonna make i'm gonna
let my calls run up and then i'm gonna
take again some profits if we go to 340
350 i'm gonna take some profits i know
you guys don't take profits and you are
right to do so but i'm a trader um
and this is the way i work i i'm gonna
take profits here and i'm gonna reload
lower because i'm gonna expect the force
wave to come
so bam bam bam
let me finish some game stop
we have many things to do guys we need
to check the synthetic shot we need to
check uh if we have some news
so all right
i'm gonna keep that drawing and then we
can expect a false wave so where this
false wave might go guys as usual we
we're gonna have
the third wave so let's assume the the
third wave goes to 350
then the false wave might go to the 270
level so if we go to 340 guys don't
formo it's not the time to buy it's the
time to
wait or even take some profits
and then if we have this pullback all
right
it would be a typical breakout then pull
back coming back to the uh trend line
support that was previously resistance
and then we're going to complete uh this
third wave uh
then let's see guys it's too early to
say but probably close to 500 or you
know something like this
uh then we're gonna have one more
pullback and then the massive fifth that
to me would go to 800 and i'm talking
about this level guys for
almost one year and you know some people
around me there start to you know really
question if i do believe in what i'm
saying
and
of course i do believe in what i'm
saying and those uh who are with me on
discord you're gonna see uh that i'm
gonna you know take positions uh to
maximize my profits for this scenario
i'm gonna you know play this scenario
as good as i can because i really
believe this is what might happen
okay let's make some cleaning here
just to have a better picture sorry
okay is it
best to trade stocks of catalysts um
not sure to understand your question bro
where is mc going
okay
so i did amc already amc to me is going
to stay around 44 for a few days and
then it's gonna uh
it's gonna run to 52 all right the
resistance is 52 consolidate here a bit
uh probably a third wave going to 70
they pull back to 50 and then 130
alright so for now it's very early of
course i'm giving you guys some
scenarios that are uh of course not um
not 100 percent sure i mean uh you know
you can't be sure of anything in uh
training but this is my preferred
scenario i mean this is what would make
sense to me and i can feel you know i'm
basically analyzing stocks every day for
many hours i'm answering all of my
members questions and
i can see that there are many many
breakouts coming right now all right uh
this is the reason why i wanted to show
you playboy guys we have a beautiful
breakout we got industry yesterday i
gave you this trade it's not a winner
yet i mean it is starting to be a winner
but i'm pretty sure we're gonna have a
run up here uh
i i'm gonna talk about bga v bby as well
but what i'm saying is that i can see
that
it's starting again you know we are in
this um environment where there are many
opportunities uh there is a flow of
money that is just growing all right
because people make money they reinvest
this money they make more money and it's
a virtual cycle
until of course the time where we have a
correction
but this is not coming right now i think
we have a few months of bull market
um
driven by
some big cap stocks that have a big
market cap like gamestop and amc so
that's why i pay attention to those two
first and then i use a bit the
information i get on those two for the
other ones and what i'm seeing on
gamestop is extremely bullish to me and
this is the reason why i'm
more positive on the other stocks i'm
analyzing
yeah come on guys give me some likes 47
not too bad but we can do better
all right
so
uh next one i want to do bg fv
um
and then i'm gonna start to check your
question bbvy i'm gonna answer that bro
very soon
very soon ocgn okay i have questions
about this one i'm coming to the
questions uh just right after but first
let me do bgf guys so
um
we were in the street
uh we entered uh when i say we i'm
talking about myself and gabrielle who
is a trader experience stranded is
helping me on discord we take our
decisions together and we decided to get
in bgfv
uh
four days ago
so the reason why is as you guys can see
we had a beautiful breakout that was
here with volume and then we just we
just bought the retest
so
we were expecting a strong move to
happen but i mean you know we we
often expect those strong moves they
don't always happen but here it happened
and we actually took profit at 32.
so
i'm checking the after market and you
know of course i feel like oh we maybe
took profits too early but the reason
why we took profits here is because we
don't have any consolidation guys here
okay
so whenever you have some consolidation
that you can call a force wave for
example or whatever um then you have
energy you have some buildup this is
called the buildup phase and it's gonna
happen i mean maybe we're gonna just go
through that and go to 50 60 you know
it's possible you know this can happen
but most of the times the market
develops in waves and here where are we
in terms of weight development let's
have a look guys
but to me i was targeting the top um of
the third to exit my position i would
re-enter later
maybe all right i was looking for
something like this
okay
so i i will not take the aftermarket
into account in my ta even if it's good
to have a look at because you know in
the after market you know what investors
want to do for tomorrow but only a small
part of investors so
it's good to have a look at it but it's
not good to use in your tier so let's do
uh the tier like this i'm gonna stay
here on the daily time frame
so we have resistance at 32 33 even so
let's see maybe we're just gonna get
dumped uh tomorrow
uh i mean today
we have one more resistance at 37. so my
guess is that the top of the third would
be here and then we're gonna have a
pullback so where are we gonna have the
pullback as usual guys around
32 maybe 30 okay
i want to show you one more thing guys
for bjv
that is very important
and this is like i said what i almost
always use whenever i want to find some
targets whenever i want to
to understand the market dynamics that
uh
would happen in any given stock bgfv
as you guys know i'm an ex option trader
i was trading option for six years
for a bank
uh so i know a bit about this market and
bjv i know especially how to retrieve
easily all the information i need
so bam all right
so let's analyze together what we have
here
so
okay
let me just put it in a way that you
guys can all see it so let me explain
again a bit what we have in here
i'm retrieving all the options all the
options up an interest from the market
so i know i don't know who is holding
what but i know what options are in this
market and i know that written investors
are usually buying calls and option
market makers are usually selling calls
to retail investors so they have a short
gamma position and what like just like i
explained before guys whenever you have
a big amount of options so how do you
know if it's big i'm gonna explain but
first you can just look at it okay so
here you can see uh and you saw the
difference with amc right you so you see
those short squeeze plays
this is the short squeeze play because
you only have option around 30. so what
is going to help the price action to go
to 50 i don't know that's why i
personally don't believe we're gonna go
to 50 i mean not right now at least
maybe in a few months uh yes but right
now i see a big amount of option around
30. why is it big because
you can see that the synthetic oh man
the dtc that is at nine all right so i
didn't see that so this is
this is very bullish all right this is
very bullish so let me explain here what
i'm trying to to check
uh all right
so uh sorry
okay so we have right now ten percent of
synthetic short okay so ten percent why
because it's the aggregated position of
all the option um all the call options
holders
uh at the current spot 31.7
now if we go to a much higher level
we're gonna go from 10
to 17
okay so we have seven percent so this is
how i check if it's big or not all right
because you know it's not because it's
bigger than the other ones that it's big
but here i can see that we have seven
percent of difference uh in the
synthetic short uh between right now and
if we go above all of these options so
roughly 40. so it means that
option market makers would need to buy
roughly seven percent of the share float
during this move
okay
so seven percent of the share floats
so it means uh seven percent
of
the share float is 20 million
so we are talking here about 1 million
shares alright
and what is the daily volume
okay
it's one million shares
okay so is we're talking here about one
daily volume all right so we know it's
big all right because if we go through
uh the strikes roughly through 30
through 35 just like we are doing right
now actually it means that option market
makers needs to buy and those guys
they might be the ones that were
actually buying in after markets i know
there was some announcement about
dividends so maybe it's retail investors
buying but you know i think everyone was
basically buying but what i'm saying is
that right now the boat it's done we
went through the third strike right uh
so we we're not gonna have those guys
with us all right maybe we're still
gonna have the retail investors that
will that would keep buying but option
market makers would not be buying any
more because those guys that delta hedge
their positions every day i i know that
because i was doing that as i just told
you um so they need to
they need to buy on the same day so they
you know they can keep a bit of uh of
short position for the next day so maybe
they're gonna buy again at the at the
open today so maybe we're gonna see a
run up to the 37 area
but then we will need at some point to
consolidate okay and this is going to be
the first wave pullback and maybe i'm
going to be a buyer here let's see
so i i uh i just sum up what i've what
i've just said we have a big amount of
option around the 3d strike this is the
reason why we uh
when we arrived that strongly on it we
went through it
um and we have resistance
around 34 37
uh and i think that after this
resistance we're gonna have a pullback
and then maybe one more move so we're
gonna need to analyze that
uh
you know
like i said i i think it's gonna be
tough to do this fifth wave but maybe
and what i'm gonna be checking
personally is you guys know that we're
gonna have some kind of a triangle uh
sorry maybe triangle but maybe zigzag
i'm just going to go do a trend line
here and if we have a breakout above
that trendline on the hourly time frame
for example then i might use that as an
entry all right this is the way i like
to trade personally
so this is what i what i what i would be
monitoring and as you guys can see if
i'm right i'm going to basically be a
buyer around 32 3 so roughly where i
sold so that's why i like to sell first
take profits
you know relax calm down
you know just feel confident about the
good training i've just done
then analyze the situation again think
about everything and then uh enter again
and usually if you uh take profits at
the right levels where you really have a
resistance
uh you can usually re-enter on the at
the same level you know a few days later
so this is the reason why i like to take
profits early uh based on the option
markets that i'm seeing and based on my
resistance levels that i found using
technical analysis
all right 64 likes guys thank you thank
you it's growing for those who haven't
liked this please do it right now
i'm gonna start to check your questions
but i still need to do bbby all right
where is bbby going tomorrow
okay
good question i'm gonna try to answer
that
um
okay
it's looking good
true
but it's not looking good all right let
me explain
so bby i'm following the stock for guys
uh
one year something like this uh the
reason why i started to be bullish is uh
here
um
on the breakout that we had in october
uh so i was i started to do my videos
around november so i don't remember what
i was saying but probably something like
you know this is a good level to buy or
something like this
all right then we finish this move and
then you guys can see that we had a
strong correction just like we had on
many meme stocks guys
um
and this correction so we can analyze
where it went to this is the first thing
we can do
i unfortunately didn't have this one in
my watch list otherwise i would probably
uh
maybe not entered but at least discussed
with um gabrielle who is working with me
or even with you guys you know um
you know maybe to enter here uh because
whenever those trend lines are broken uh
once again log scale guys if you try to
do this kind of trend lines with a
regular scale just let me show you how
it looks
it's not too bad
actually
okay this one is not too bad
but sometimes you just have uh
it's completely different okay it's just
fitting not too bad
uh
but it's not the same trend line you can
see i'm having here only two highs
and i'm missing i'm not exactly on the
retest let me go back to the log scale
okay
right now i'm back to the logarithmic
scale that is taking into account uh
movement in percentage and not in
absolute value and you guys can see that
this trend line is much much better all
right so if you want to do this kind of
trend lines on some long term press
action you absolutely need to do it in
logarithmic scale so just right click
here log scale okay very important
and on the shorter term it's not going
to affect the price at all all right log
and regular scales are the same
on the short term but very different on
the long term and the right one to use
on the long term to me is the log scale
and this is a nice example all right
here i'm connecting this high this high
uh i'm having here as well kind of a
connection uh once again guys
unintersect all right uh
i just told you at the beginning of this
video that the market likes to go
through those intersects and this is
exactly what happened here okay we had
this the here the maximum uh
it was the the previous high and we had
this trend line that we can do that you
could have done already in december 16
guys you know five years ago
and the market went through that all
right but this is not the point of what
i wanted to show you here then we had
this retest and then the strong move up
okay so i'm coming to what what is
happening right now but what i'm saying
is that here we had a support level that
you know
many buyers will probably hear
and let me zoom in a little bit and
analyze what is happening right now so
right now guys
as i just you know did on the long term
i'm gonna do the same on the shorter
term so i'm doing my trend line
connecting the highs here and here
and
you know
okay let's be honest if i really want to
do the strength and perfectly i would
have done it like this okay
okay so we went through it
and we got basically
rejected by i think uh a bit of this
trend line and a bit of the 200-day
moving average that is located at 26.4
so we opened the day here and what
happened during the day guys nothing
good bears were in full control they
were just um
you know
selling selling selling so i checked the
news on this one and we had some uh
announcement about you know the the
company business that is you know i
don't remember exactly but some good
news about the business that is gonna be
better
uh for the coming uh weeks and months uh
even years
uh and this is what created this strong
move up but let's be honest guys uh you
know how it's working right
and
investors
don't
only buy on news they buy on fomo they
buy on momentum they they
you know money follows the money you
know this is how it's working and to me
it's not the news that created the
strong move up analysts are gonna say
it's the news because analysts they
don't do technical analysis i'm gonna
tell you that it's gme that created all
of this and amc you know those two
stocks that have you know 20 billion usd
of market capitalization uh they are
driving everything all right and here
to me this move is
mostly due to the rally we had uh in uh
gme and um amc and it's basically the
same investors guys that you know
are in those place so
right now let me
all right sorry
i want to check the synthetic shot i'm
going to check the gamma for bjv
and i want to finish my analysis so bam
bam bam okay
so first
okay so
bga v so you guys can see nine uh just
to conclude this is
one more reason to be bullish nine is a
lot let me check if i have some
information about bjv in the past
uh
okay you can see the between september
and november's in the past two months
the gtc went from five to nine so this
is one of the reasons we had this uh
squeeze yesterday but once again i think
this quiz is uh done for bjv bbby let's
see let's see you guys know what i what
i'm looking for right now i'm looking
for some very upside gamma
if i have this very upset gamma just
like i have on amc and gamestop
um
it's good
it's good it means that option market
makers are gonna be massively uh buying
on the upside
all right so first information uh three
thirty one percent of total short
interest so it's big okay
we're gonna then check what we had uh
previously but it's bigger
market cap 1.8 billion all right
and this is what is interesting to me so
we can go from eight to 18 percent uh in
the synthetic short interest and we have
gamma located at 20
and at 30. okay so this is good you guys
can see the gamma is big at 30 is not
small all right
i just remind you guys with the one we
just checked before it's not the same
shape look
okay you can see we have a big one at 30
and then a much smaller one at
35 and nothing at 40. let me go back on
dbui
okay
okay let me go back on dbui
oh
all right
and you guys can see here so we have the
same around the money at 20
then we have almost the same amount at
25 and we have
almost the same amount at 30. so this is
first information i have that is more
bullish
now
let's
come back to the price action so
um
so this is the reason why i think we had
this massive gap up but then the price
action got sold massively
so i have different information you know
coming from the technical analysis and
coming from the option market the option
market is telling me that if we go
strongly higher we should amplify the
moves but we still had a plus 15
yesterday so we cannot say the move was
not strong but it could have been much
stronger
then uh second information i have is
that we didn't manage to close above 24
so if we have a close above let's call
it let's use the 200-day moving average
because this trend line as you guys know
it can be done a little bit like that so
i prefer to have the resistance at the
same level
so if we close above 26 i would turn
bullish and i'm happy to see that we
have this gamma around 30 okay
so it's quite good once again the gamma
is it big or not we're talking here
about
eight percent of the total share float
um
and the daily volume
is
okay so 12 million training every day 12
12 million shares
and roughly eight million
off
sorry eight it's even nine percent
so it's 0.09 times
the share float
so we have how much gamma ah come on
bam
share float 93 million so we have all
right
8 million of gamma and 12 million
trading every day so roughly
uh
70 of a daily volume uh
of gamma so
it's it's big but it's uh smaller than
we the one we just saw on bgfv uh at a
lower strike
so right now what can we do on bbb why i
personally would not get into this trade
uh the reason why is because this move
down is too sharp too strong and bears
are too much confident for me to try to
go against that i don't like to you know
try to catch a falling knife this is
what we say you know in trading um
whenever the market is crashing you
always have some traders that you know
they just try to buy it you know just
because they have a support level
um i've been doing that right
and i burned uh my uh myself doing that
you know
it usually end ups quite badly when uh
you try to buy uh in a folding market
like this so what i would personally do
so we have a support at uh 17.7 so you
know setting up an order here just
buying around 18 stop loss at 16 is a
third try all right you risk two points
and you can make maybe 10 points so you
have a risk reward of five so it's it's
it's a trade that is doable what i would
personally do i would wait to see what
happens here and if i have a small
consolidation
uh and then
i'm able to draw a small trend line and
then i have a breakout here
then i would get in alright so you can
see the type of trading i like to do i
like to buy
uh low
on a short-term buddish signal alright
so maybe i'm gonna miss it maybe
it's just gonna be like that
fair enough but guys there's so many
opportunities today in the market i
don't care if i miss one you know i'm
gonna go to the next one so i feel good
doing uh that and not financial advice
but
keep in mind guys that it's better to
buy something that is already showing
you some bullish signals
uh so that you put your money in
something hot you know you don't want to
put your money in something cold all
right even if you buy here at 14 you
know it's a good level but you need to
keep your money in that for maybe one
month maybe two months maybe even one
year before making profits so you're not
going to lose money but you're just
going to miss all the other
opportunities that you could have
got if you would have put your money in
what is hot
so
you know just keep that in mind this is
something i try to apply to myself i
sometimes do want to buy something that
you know is just cheap
but
i have experienced that it's actually
not the best way to um
make uh to maximize your profits the
best way to maximize your profits is to
buy something that is just starting to
go up okay this is what i am trying to
do
so i think i'm done on bbby so i repeat
uh i would personally uh so we have
support at 18. uh i would personally not
try to get in right now i would wait to
see if we have some consolidation and
some short-term bullish signals and
whenever we have a close above 26
i would turn uh bullish on the long run
for the reasons that i gave you it's
because we have a nice gamma around 30
and i'm gonna check how this is moving
um so yeah this is uh what i have to say
on bbby
so i have a last one to do playboy but i
could keep it for the end i'm gonna
start to check your questions
all right so
please hit the like folks thanks bro
thanks brother
and if we do go under 205 good question
okay
on gamestop if we go below 205 it just
means that the third wave is probably
complete
it means that we we lost the momentum
all right we don't want to lose the
momentum we need the momentum the
momentum is uh that's you know
it is meaning that everybody is fomo
following so we need to keep that and if
we go below 205 we're losing that all
right so it doesn't mean we're going to
go much lower it just means that we
would probably you know go to the
we will probably go to there all right
it's gonna be something here and we we
we might be waiting you know
one more month or two a month
before having this uh close above the
orange trend line
so this is what could happen we could
also revisit the lows coming back to the
1178 level i personally
think it's
very very unlikely we break that okay
um
because
you know because of all the money in the
market because of everything that is
happening around gme around the gaming
industry right now um around the meme
stocks you know so i personally do
believe this will hold uh but the
alternative scenario is just that we you
know we slowly uh converge towards the
end of this triangle which is around 200
in gen 22. so this is the alternative
scenario but
seriously
it's not looking like that it's looking
impulsive it's looking like we're going
to 300 350. so
i prefer
this scenario
okay
honey yes hey bro
okay where is mc going so i answered
that already amc is going to uh
i don't know i think it's going to
consolidate below 44 and if we do break
44 uh probably gonna have one more
consolidation above around 52 and let's
be honest if we break
break out above 44
it's
almost a done thing i mean it it would
look really really good for this uh
major fist wave to develop and that is
going to 130 so let's say that if we
close above 44 i would personally
increase my position a lot and believe
um
even more strongly in uh the scenario
that we go to 130 which is my target for
around six months and i can see that all
the guys are using this target as well
which is great i mean the more the the
better right
but um
but it's my target for six months and i
believe we're gonna go there
130 he said yes aaron thanks for
following uh then
no i didn't say 120 so
then consolidation
i didn't say consideration to 270
but maybe maybe this is the next fib uh
extension ratio so if you want to
discuss about that
uh okay yeah all right i know what you
mean
i said that indeed we have a lot of
options on the 145 strike so if we do
actually go through 135
i personally think we're going to go to
maybe more 200 you know something like
this this is the next level uh i
personally don't think we can go much
higher than 200
in one move but then maybe we can
consolidate for a few more months and
then do one more run why not but in this
fifth wave i personally think that 130
is a nice target and 200 would be
would be what we would got thanks to the
option market because once again i show
you that again guys
but we have a massive massive massive
amount of option on the 145 strike
okay it's not working anymore what's
happening with my spreadsheet all right
bam
bam
and bam bam bam
come on
ah this is blocked
all right so here you go 145 strike 20
million options i mean
uh
200 000 options which is 20 million
equivalent shares uh and for example on
the 40 strike how many we have
uh 5 million so we have four times more
options trading on the 145 strike gen 22
so once again that's why i believe this
scenario can happen before jan 22
because this is where we have the
options but i'm gonna be monitoring if
we have a role from gen 2 to gen 23 if
the scenario didn't happen yet so let's
follow that it's going to be interesting
to see
okay guys
maybe we go to 43 tomorrow yeah i think
we might do that
so bb
so
bbby are answered already uh i think
we're gonna consolidate uh around uh 17
18 for a few days this is my view and
then let's see what happens
great to see you live streaming yeah
carlos thanks bro i'm very happy to be
here and thank you all guys for being
there with me as well
so you think amc will go back to 38
uh maybe
but quickly if it gets back to 38 it's
gonna be bought quickly uh
what i think is that
below 38 it's we're losing the momentum
um
but if i needed to buy i would buy
rather around 39 or 40. you know 38 is
the level i mean the minimum level that
i don't want to see the price action
going below but i'm pretty sure they're
going to be a lot of buyers
above 38s so not sure we're going to
touch 38
better 39 or 40.
come on guys bring me 200 likes i have
85 right now
it's looking good
we almost there
all right
hey
oh sorry
hi okay
okay so here i was there already
i love your work what about tesla okay i
can show you tesla quickly
yes guys 93 likes this is looking great
thank you so much
wkhs i did that yesterday i can do it
again
attair and matt okay
okay
okay guys i'm gonna go through your uh
questions very soon let me show you
playboy first uh you know this is the
kind of place that i'm sharing with my
community on discord and
you know i can show you a bit uh
how i
uh how i'm looking for those because
basically this is a nice example of um a
play that i like to do so for now once
again uh it's starting well but maybe
it's you know we're just going to get
stopped so do what i'm looking for when
i'm chasing uh some good stocks to buy
i'm looking for a usually double or
triple signal so once again i like to
buy low but whenever i have some bullish
signals so here
uh the reason why
i entered into this trade is because we
had this uh long consolidation of a few
months all right first thing where we
don't go lower you know we have higher
highs we could even have lower lower
lows sorry higher lows we could even had
some lower lows it would be fine but
what i don't like to see is something
sharp and you can see that since the
19th of august the price action is very
steady kind of neutral uh we clearly
have a resistance at 30 30.4 that is
touch that has been touched once twice
three four you know six times and then
we have this uh typical reversal pattern
sorry
i missed my drawing
okay 99 likes guys we're almost there
bam
cup and handle all right and the reason
why
i entered this trade is because we had a
close here
uh
so two days ago
at 30
30.91
and this was the first time we were
closing above 30.4 so here is my bullish
signal so i had this signal and i didn't
have the breakout above the blue trend
line yet
but um
but let's be honest if you wait for this
breakout you're gonna buy higher so the
the earlier the better but you need to
buy earlier with many bullish signals so
here we have a new high okay so this is
the breakout above the cuphead handle we
have a nice consideration in the past
two months and we have a nice
consideration in the past week that is
forming this handle so and we are very
close to the breakout area and of course
the reason why as well i like i wanted
to enter in playboy is because those
guys they're going to create some nfts
um i'm not sure what what kind of
picture they're going to put in it but i
you know i have some ideas you can use
your imagination as well
and i think you know it's just very
interesting for investors you know to
talk about it so i think
there can be some
um
some you know some chatter around
playboy so about playboy so this is the
reason why for all these reasons i want
you to enter in this trade and for now
it's looking great guys it is not
financial advice but it's still good to
buy
uh i
you see the after
market where is the aftermarket
i saw the aftermarket much higher so i
don't know where it's gonna open but you
know if i was not in that trade i would
personally just place a buying order
around 31
with the stop loss around you know 20
24 just below the slow okay so whenever
you have a cap and a handle uh
you can buy on the breakout and use the
low of the handle as a stop loss so here
the low of the handle is
25.2
so i would personally use a stop loss at
25 and this is a real trend that i
really took yesterday uh and i'm quite
confident about that this is why i
wanted to share it with you guys
hi bro what's up man
oh yeah man
all right
wkhs
okay so bam bam i'm trying to check
quickly
what are the stocks you guys want to see
the most bbg sup my man what's up hey
bro
okay
so let's do
[Music]
okay let's do tesla quickly
uh
so you guys know i'm bullish on tesla uh
i see
um
we are in a major fifth wave that is
going to 2000 to me
so this is my target for maybe
next year right in one year uh but i do
believe we can reach it uh for now we
are only in the third wave and inside
the third wave we are in the third wave
so we are in a third of a third of a
fifth so you heard third twice
so this is very impulsive because third
waves are the most impulsive
i'm not sure we have completed the third
or not i don't really have any uh tool
to estimate um how high a third wave can
go i know where fifth wave can go all
right i mean you know i'm just using
that
okay but i don't really have uh any tool
to measure how high a third wave can go
so it's just visual alright
it's just visual and here
1300
you know seems reasonable for this third
wave
what we can do is measure
here in the past uh how it how it
happened this is the only thing we can
do so here i had inside this third wave
i'm gonna measure the first wave
and i'm gonna apply it to the bottom of
the second wave okay and i can see that
this third wave is going to do 3.618
ratio so assuming the same thing happens
the same things the same thing happens
then i measure the first wave
bam applied to the bottom of the of the
second wave
sorry it's not very clean
oh sorry the second uh
no no no i missed that okay this first
wave is here
and the second wave is here and the
3.618 is
1260. so this is my target for the third
wave um i'm not very confident about
this target but this is the best i can
do
and i personally would not buy now of
course guys i mean if you're not in the
street it's of course not a good idea to
get in not financial advice but
not a good idea
what
i would try to do
maybe i'm not sure
is to once we have uh the third wave
complete i'm going to measure it and i'm
going to enter on the 38.2 or 50
and you guys can see so this is one
method
i'm using fib ratios to measure
the third wave
uh and enter in the force and you can
see then i don't know if it's 1070 1000
1020 you know
but what i know is that i have a
consolidation around 1020
so this is for me the level uh to buy
all right if i wanted to buy tesla i
would get in at 1020 1030
with a target for this third wave around
1400 after pullback and fifth wave so i
think tesla has a huge potential uh then
at 1 500 i would get out of it and wait
for the force wave correction
oh right i have 600 shares of amc
cool bro
jme can touch 800 soon i don't know if
it's gonna be soon bro
i mean it can happen
quickly
but it can also take a few weeks month
all right so
i think that gen 22 is an important uh
time because it's the end of those
triangles all right
as you can see so we need to you know
take a direction and i'm pretty sure
it's going to be on the upside uh and
then we need to wait the fives the five
waves to develop so you know it can go
very quickly but it can go a bit uh
slower as well so i don't know let's say
before march 22 all right this is the
best i can say
if gamestop crosses 508 then next
resistance is 1600
we will moon chill in time
yes yes
why not it's possible as well of course
if we go to 800 there is a massive
strike at 950 so let me show you that
i didn't show you guys this
so let's check
gamestop
okay
and bam
and look
guys seriously four million equivalent
shares under 950 strikes strike on game
on game stop so that's a lot all right
uh that's
a bit the same um amount like that we
have on amc i mean if we compare to what
we have uh close to the money so the
money is around 200 so the 200 we have
around 1.5 million and we have roughly
three times more on the 950 strike so
for the same reason if we
come close to it so we need to come to
900 all right even 800 might do the job
already so if we get close to that level
anything can happen let's be honest and
we can very well
just go through it
and then
um
go to 1200 i don't know 800 is my target
but i'm not saying it cannot go higher
all right that's what i am you know
reaching 100 by monday yeah i hope so
bro
okay
so nico weisner bb okay i can do bb bbig
uh
prague prague is dead guys i think uh i
would stay out of prague i was in that
trade that took profits at 4 and 3 15.
roughly i was having calls i got out of
it and the volume is low now
so
okay
i'm gonna start so
bbig let's do bbig
okay
so bbsg guys um
it was a bit of love story between me
and dbig guys you know it's one of the
first plays i was actually pushing on my
discord
and
it was a success
at first and then
and then it got you know just like in
relationships we had our good time and
then it didn't work so well anymore so
i'm right now staying out of it but
um
i can tell you
uh what i think the reason why i'm
staying out is so i was in this trade
here at four for the first time
i didn't manage to take profits here but
uh i hope some of you guys did
and then i re-entered this trade here on
this uh like i said whenever we have a
correction
we can uh use a short-term breakout to
enter for the next wave and here guys uh
on bbig we had this
um
trendline we had this breakout with
volume once again guys whenever you have
a breakout never never forget to check
the volume it's very important a
breakout without volume is most likely a
fake out so here we are the breakout
with volume uh so we bought here
uh we were in this trade we were happy
to be in
and
and and we got stopped all right the
there was just no more gas uh it
couldn't go higher
uh
so i'm gonna check the option market but
what's happening from there
okay this trend line became useless
so it's weak volume is going lower so
that's not positive all right now let's
check if we have some nice support
levels that can
bring us some fresh energy
and even the 200-day moving average is
not actually very used uh you can see it
was not acting well as support in the
past so i don't see why it would this
time so i don't have a support here
um
you see whenever you don't have a clean
support
where bulls can you know just gather
their strengths and together go in to
the to the do this trade
uh it makes it easier for the bears all
right and here
i don't see any clear
okay the best i can do is four okay four
is a support actually four is a support
it's a support white because we have the
200 day moving average so like i said
it's not giving good reaction in the
past but it's still the 200-day moving
average so you cannot just ignore it so
we have it
then uh i'm checking here the highs in
this move as you guys can see
and
i'm trying to pick up one of those that
has some consolidation and previous
reactions and this one here at 412 had
one two
reactions here a lot of small reactions
consolidations and here a nice reaction
so and even here guys all right
so four is the support level so i might
get back in one more time let's see
uh but i lost money on this trade let's
be honest
so it's never good to go back in a trade
where you actually lost money
sorry guys i'm coming back just give me
a sec
all right stay with me i'm back guys
so
um i was saying four is uh is a strong
support actually okay
so
if i needed to get in i would buy at 410
420 and i would stop loss around 370.
now
let's have a look at the option market
okay guys bbig was absolutely insane
okay and we lost it all right
guys bbig i don't know
i i don't know i don't believe in it
anymore
uh check okay so
look what we had in the past
okay i'm following this since the 1st of
september
even
august and look guys the synthetics the
synthetic short was at
95 guys 95
all right
the total shot was at 92 percent 60 25
22. all right the day to to to cover was
2.5 in august and this is why we had
this run up now the dtc is at one
so there is no pressure on shorts and
there are no more shots actually in this
market all right
the regular shot uh is lower so shots
have covered already and the synthetic
shot is dropping heavily it's still at
decent levels all right um
it's still a decent level we still have
22 percent of total short interest so
synthetic plus
regular
uh where is it coming from so you can
see it's coming from the five
and
seven point five level roughly
what's that six so five and six
and it's not that small all right so
so this is the reason why as well guys
it's working on both sides all right uh
so whenever we go through five and six
that's why here we are this strong moves
all right in both ways on the upside on
the downside all right we go strongly in
one way strongly in the other way why
because market makers they need to buy
whenever it's going higher but they need
to sell whenever it's going lower all
right so it's just um
working in both ways
so here if we go to four
and
then we start to move higher
i think we can go to seven
but i don't think we can go much higher
than that all right i mean
at the moment if people start to get in
the trade and i can see and i see the
option market growing yes i would try to
get back in
but here let's be honest the only trade
to do is to buy here and sell here all
right
so buy at four
sell at 6.5
and it's still a 50
profits so
i might be doing this trade but i think
here we're going to get rejected and do
the same thing again and then maybe
we're gonna have a breakout but we need
some news we need you know a catalyzer
we need people to talk about it
right now uh the flows are you know just
uh
going out from bbig not in all right so
i would stay away i would stay away uh
same thing for other guys uh i was in
that trend i didn't make money
um
i mean twice i almost did money you know
i wanted to buy here i missed it for a
little
i wanted to buy here and in the end i
didn't uh so that's why you know i
didn't want to let it go but sometimes
you just need to let it go all right
you know i know that it's not good to go
back in the trade where you lost money
and i still did it and
um i mean i didn't lose money first i
just didn't get in and then i bought at
uh eight something like this here i
bought here on the support
um and i got stopped at seven all right
and right now it's
just like i was saying yesterday it's
not looking great to me because we are
below the moving averages uh below the
seven support level
uh below
the breakout trend line
and we have volumes decreasing
so
nothing for me to be bullish nothing
uh can we go higher yes of course we can
go higher but it's not bullish i mean if
we go higher
just
luck to me
so let's check what we have on the
option market
not bad
not too bad ah dtc 0.5 okay not good
guys we need a dtc as you as you saw
guys bga v has nine i mean uh bbby had
five amc gme they have three four you
know those things that go strongly
higher they have a high dtc here we have
0.5
so despite the very low volume all right
so
that's it
it's just you know i think otter
might wake up but later all right right
now i don't say it's gonna go lower
right if you buy you're not gonna lose a
lot
um
but i think that better place at the
moment
than utter
then what else can we check yes we have
7.5 and 10 so if we start to uh
you know
let's try to find a breakout
that we can use but as you saw guys even
on bbig we had it and then we didn't go
higher so i would say that if utter
comes numb even there are too many bag
holders guys i would stay away you know
because even if you get in at 8 50
what are you going to do you're going to
take profits at 10 11. and if you don't
some other
investors will do it all right so you
better do so it means you play for two
points and you're gonna risk one or two
points
the risk reward is like not great
so yes utter is not a play i would
personally get in right now
you think there is a lot of calls on
bbig that's why that's why it's running
sideways
uh
it's not exactly like what i said i said
that on bbig let me show you again
there used to be many calls all right
there used to be a lot of options
uh and right now we still have some
options around six
and five
so whenever we're gonna go through that
so through five through six the moves
are gonna be amplified that's what i'm
saying and this is maybe one of the
reasons i mean not maybe this is for
sure one of the reasons but not the only
one
that we had this move up here and move
down here that were strong we're talking
here about 20 moves guys right so that's
a lot okay that's not two five ten
percent it's twenty percent
so whenever those uh strong moves happen
usually you have some big option uh open
interest behind
those levels that's what i'm saying
yeah please hit the like button
i agree thanks phil
wkhs
okay hey bro what's up
okay so wkhs many of you are asking
i like your elliot wave on amc looks
like we are on way five yes bro i agree
looks like that to me as well
and matt okay i can do sub bro
okay i can do wkhs
okay so
bam
wkhs
so we have this is a situation that i
like to follow all right i'm not bullish
yet
but i like to follow it why because as
you can see we had
a typical impulse up one two three four
five we can
check
if it was respecting fib
ratios
wow okay so here you can see
when was that
okay because it was so low okay so you
see when the premium is that low fib
extensions are not relevant okay but we
are we were trading around one
uh
so it's just a good information to keep
in mind then we had this abc correction
okay
so
what else can we say i have here a trend
line but i can see the trendline is not
perfect
okay this is much better so here we have
support so guys this is looking great
okay we have this trendline support that
has been a bit um not respected
perfectly but
it's it's all right to me
we had this abc correction
uh here that is
maybe complete let's check how deep we
have retraced but once again for those
we are coming from the lows
so
yeah i'm not surprised the correction is
extremely deep
because uh because we're trading close
to zero so it's not that relevant to use
field extensions and uh i mean
projections and retracements on this
kind of moves
so
wkhs is very interesting because
you guys can see that we have uh a
breakout that is very close okay the
breakout is around eight eight fifty
we already have some bullish signals
before breakout okay we have the volumes
going higher
all right
it's pretty clear
that the volumes is that the volumes are
going higher they're going higher before
breakout okay so that's a good signal an
early signal but a good signal what else
do we have we have here
uh
you know
we can call it a double bottom or i
don't know how you want to call it but
we had clearly a resistance at seven
that was tested a few times in the past
a few days hey happy bee what's up bro
um
and suddenly we broke it so we didn't uh
have the breakouts off
sorry
of the major resistance line around 830
but we have a smaller breakout here
that is now support all right seven was
resistance
and it is now support
so guys i'm actually i think i'm gonna
get in today
you know i'm just gonna buy
around 7.2
stop loss
you know good question where to put the
stop loss here
i think i'm going to put the stop loss
i'm going to take some room i'm going to
put the stop loss here below the slows
around six so i buy 7 20 i stop loss at
six
and i'm playing this breakout and if it
does break out we're gonna run to 11
quickly so i'm risking one point to make
four points risk reward of four it's
full of sense so i like this display
uh it's not fully bullish yet but it's
looking like something is happening
um
let me check again i forgot
i think it's eevee right they doing ev
yes so battery for uh
they electric vehicles so
you guys know that the sector is booming
tesla is booming uh i got in bl nk as
well yesterday i can show you that later
but let's check first uh what is the
synthetic short what is the option
market showing us for
um wkhs
okay
let's save utter you know we're gonna
use it maybe later
okay wkhs
okay
habibi bro i saw you i saw you you put
bb like a thing five times i'm gonna do
bb just right after i promise i finish
wkhs
and i do bb guys look okay
i'm gonna post this one in my discord
today
why because like i said we have
everything that is looking great we have
increasing volumes before breakout we
are
above one moving average not the 50 but
only only the 20 which is good enough we
have a new high above the recent
consolidation we are getting close to
the breakout area
um
do we have
and we have i think the buddhist
divergence and bam we do have the
british divergence so we have many
bullish signals uh that are going into
the same direction a bullish divergence
for those who forgot i don't know what
it is it's whenever the price action is
making lower lows so we going lower
but with the momentum going higher so
it's just showing that a lot of bears
are actually uh
not bears anymore and start to be buyers
and that's why the momentum so we don't
have enough strength to make deeper uh
lows so bears are basically not able to
really take ground um you know in a good
way and this is usually a reversal sign
uh i like to combine those bullish
divergences with breakouts so here we
have a short-term breakout above seven
we don't have the medium-term breakout
above 8-30 but i think it will happen
uh and once again yes this is what i
wanted to to show you look guys
bam oh it's nice okay everything is good
double i like wkhs thank you for telling
me
uh i was already having it in my watch
list yesterday as you guys can see
uh bam bam bam
so what did i put yesterday
you see
8.70
so i didn't pay
attention enough to it yesterday so
thank you for showing that to me again
uh and i didn't check actually the
synthetic short and here look we have
the 10 we have the 15. is it big or not
let's answer that but i can already tell
you it's big because i i see the dtc at
six so let's compute how much gamma we
have we have eight percent of gamma
eight percent of gamma
uh times the number of shares
so
sorry them equal to this times
share float all right so 10 million uh
of
shares of gamma
and the daily volume
is
we want to see something around one
daily volume or even higher sorry i
missed
that
9 million okay so 10 million of gamma
versus
uh
9 million of daily volumes so we have a
one-to-one relation so it's a lot all
right it's a lot it's just like we had
on bgav and look what bgav did
so we have a lot of
good signals let me check the
aftermarket i hope it's not already
higher
perfect
okay
i'm gonna get in wkhs today guys thank
you for telling me that
so
what else bibi yes i promised so here we
go
all right so i did bb yesterday but
let's do it again
so what happened here
hmm
okay
okay so first
let's analyze the situation on the
longer term
uh i'm not gonna do my counting here but
i could one two three that's not clean
one two three four
it might be a force wave but it's not a
beautiful force wave i don't know what
it is it might be a big triangle
uh whatever uh
what i see is that we had this
descending wedge pattern all right that
got broken around 10 15 10 15. okay
broken then we had some resistance at
the previous high which is
kind of normal all right
then we had the re-test at 10.6
this is the typical trade i would like
to have done but you know there's so
many stocks i didn't see this one
but here it was a beautiful level to buy
because you have this consolidation you
have the buddhist divergence and you
have the re-test of the breakout area
and of the breakout trend line just
above the moving averages so this is the
perfect setup that unfortunately i
didn't do but it's just good for you
guys to see what uh setups are to me
good to trade
and right now what is happening so let's
check the volumes volumes going higher
that's great price action going higher
volumes going higher that's great we are
above the moving averages that's great
we have the breakout and bullish
divergence that's great
what is not
so great is that we tried to close above
12 and we didn't manage to do that so
that's not good but it's not too bad we
are just close to it so my take is that
we're gonna consolidate here and then
maybe break out
so it's too late to get in for now
because even if we close here we might
still get rejected so you know
there is no point to buy at 12 30
when you can actually wait and maybe buy
at 13 in a better setup so i would
personally not get in right now but i'm
gonna keep an eye on it
um we might also very well just you know
go right through it
and if you really believe in that i mean
yes it's not a bad timing to buy not
financial advice
but uh
technically speaking it's not the
perfect timing to get in the perfect
timing once again is to wait for a close
above 12
then re-test and you know some
consolidation see what happens here not
buying too early you know waiting one
week is i think good here uh and see if
next week we're still above 12 and below
13 if yes if we are in this area uh
this is what we call the build up area
this is the area i personally like to
trade whenever i have some positive
things uh
signals like i i do have here
or just wait for the breakout
so
this is my view i think we might just uh
consolidate
around this levels
um
let's check the option market
and if you do have shares of course it's
good to keep it
hey not bad
really
nice
not bad at all all right
it's looking great
the option market is looking great
uh dtc at six
it's a lot once again guys you might see
a different dtc from what i do because
my dtc is taking into account
actually the synthetic shot and the
regular shot so
it's a global dtc but it's the one uh
that we need to um to use all right all
the the regular dtc is uh useless to me
because sometimes you have four or five
times more synthetic short than regular
short so the only way to really use the
short information and the gamma
information is to use
a global dtc that i get uh
computing the
position coming from the option market
so let's check the gamma six percent
all right uh
six percent of gamma so we have 500
million shares
so it's uh
3 million shares
all right
sorry 30 million shares
and the daily volume is
wow
it's 10 million
so three times the daily volume
all right
that's that's very bullish
it's the from all the ones we did today
it's the one where the option market
sorry i have the sun coming to my face
okay from all the stocks we've done
we've seen today um
technically
i mean on the option market it's the one
that is the most explosive let's be
honest okay
technically
it's not perfect i would have preferred
to get in lower but once again we still
early here
and we can still uh have some
opportunities to get in between 12. i
would not get in if we don't close above
12 above 12 i will start to consider it
and
and then you guys see like the gtc's
that is at six
uh
okay the total shot is not that big he's
only at 13
but still as the daily volume is very
low it's a lot compared to the daily
volume which is the right thing to do we
need to compare this to daily volume
um
all right
so
yes where is the gamma coming from
10
15 20. all right guys that's good that's
good
it's not only
10 or 12 all right we have 15 and we
have 20.
so
we might very well do something like
this
okay
it would make sense
if i was in that trade
i would uh
i would take my first profits here
around 16
just above the 15 because the 15 is the
biggest one all right
and 20 as well okay i would take 16 but
most likely we might go just above 20
okay so 22
all this area between 16 and 22 23 okay
this is where we might be going if we
have the breakout above the blue trend
line but first we need to get this
breakout and before that breakout we
need to trade above 12 and we need to
stay above 12 for at least one week all
right so i sum up the situation if we
close above 12 we consolidate uh close
to the breakout trend line above the
previous high at 12
and we have a breakout
then i think that we're gonna run up to
the 20 area quite fast
all right
so i did bb and matt okay i saw you i
saw you bro
m matt okay naked bb
and matt
sun won't be here for another three four
hours yes but yeah for me like uh what
time is it 4pm
i have two more hours of sun so i think
i'm gonna stay with you guys a bit more
and i'm gonna enjoy a bit the day when i
still can before coming back and trade
because as you guys know
you know my schedule is a bit funny you
know i basically work in the morning i
usually have some you know
chill time in the afternoon and work
again uh
during the night
because it's the u.s market and i am in
hong kong but not for long guys i'm
coming back to france and then i'm
coming to the us i'm gonna see you guys
so
uh
matt
first impression
nothing
okay
what are they doing
okay i forgot i think i've checked that
before but i forgot
it's like construct constructions
something like this
okay meta materials material photo nyx
company
designed to pioneer nucleus include
metamodel okay okay okay now it's
interesting
meta materials all right
okay
let's see if they have earnings coming
soon
okay i don't have any information about
that here
um
okay let's first do some tm
hey bro thanks thank you so much man i'm
waiting for you there
uh okay
so
i'm trying to understand what's
happening on the stock you know
so give me some time
okay i start to see it
one two one two three four five three
four five all right okay
we're getting in bam this is a minor
wave you can see that inside i have
five waves as well up
this is
my nut let's put it in yellow
bam
okay
so i have a typical and
here as well
okay
so we can see that this stock is
following elliot wave theory quite well
true
we have impulse moves up in
five waves moves down in three waves
right
it's actually pretty
pretty clean
pretty clean i'm not gonna add one more
but i could do a small abc here let's
check now if it's following
uh fibs so i measure one plus three
you see guys okay good example
you have one plus three you applied to
the bottom of the fourth and uh it gives
you the 1.618 is 17. 17
so
i like
i'm gonna keep analyzing the stock
because
you know you can't apply fibs and elliot
to any stock you need to apply to stocks
that followed it well in the past and
here it's close to perfection okay
because we have exactly what uh
fibonacci and elliot are saying all
right especially elliot fibonacci
uh he's a mathematician from the 12th
century so he was not saying much about
training actually
but um he was basically making theories
about um every growing process and
saying that everything that is
developing is following the golden
number and eliat just applied this to
finance and to stocks
saying that there is nothing better to
illustrate the development of
the
um of demands
economy than the stock market so
now let's see if the false wave
is correcting
okay so the force wave is very deep
here
okay actually it's better the first wave
is going to do 38.2 50 okay i'm just
checking if fibs are respected or not in
the stock because if they are then
they're most likely uh they are more
likely to be uh respected again
so i'm gonna check the second wave
pullback okay a second wave to the 61.8
percent that makes sense
so it's pretty good
seriously uh
it's pretty nice
i'm gonna come to the analysis soon and
bam and look guys once again
i apply fib extensions to oneplus plus
three and it gives me 8.4 so it works
here it works here it works pretty much
everywhere so we can assume
right now that we have done this
preliminary analysis
that
we still gonna have uh
those ratios respected and uh the
um and the elliot wave patterns are
forming so we completed let me get rid
of the small ones now that i have
checked with you guys that
it's respected well okay
now i'm gonna focus on a larger degree
wave counting so we completed one two
three four five so we're expecting an
abc
and
not good
not good just looking at that of of
course it's not enough but just looking
at the eliot with counting
i'm missing a c wave all right i'm
missing a c wave
so
i would be careful it doesn't need to be
very deep but
it's looking to me that we might go to
the 250 area all right but maybe
the abc was here okay
so let's
just imagine it was here then what would
that mean it would mean that we are
doing
one
two
and then maybe we have three four five
okay
i'm here just trying to see what fits
the best
let's put it in blue
okay
now let's check let's check if the
second wave
pullback has actually respected the fib
ratios or not
amazingly yes
all right so exactly yes i would say
here
uh it's perfect 61.8 was at 420 you guys
can see we had a small dip here that got
bought quickly and then again
so
it might be a second wave so maybe this
counting is actually correct
so if this is correct
then we should have a third wave
and if we do have a third wave we're
looking for a short-term breakout that
we do have and we are above the moving
averages
so guys the more i check that stock the
more bullish
i am
okay we have here a breakout
confirmed one two three candles
it's looking great actually so i mean
setting up
buying here
with the stop loss around
four
you know you risk basically okay let's
put the stop loss at 390 so you risk one
point and if it's really a third wave
which is possible because and growing
volume i forgot to mention that breakout
first thing we do whenever we have a
breakout we check the volume and the
volume is here so we have increasing
volume short-term breakout
we are above the moving averages it
seems that uh we just completed a second
wave that we traced 61.8 percent of the
first wave which is the usual
thing just like it happened in the past
just like i checked with you guys uh in
the past
so um
[Music]
so we might very well be in the third
wave very well and if we do
if we are in the third wave where would
it go it's hard to say uh like i said i
don't really have targets for third
waves so the only thing we can use
i don't like this resistance
you know it's visual right so around 12
maybe so guys it's like 7.41 point risk
it's a nice risk it's a nice risk reward
uh have i checked
the option market
if we have a lot of options where do we
want those options guys we want them
um
around six
right
six
in all this area if we have a lot of
options between six and 10
is great
it means that the third wave might be
explosive and that it might actually be
really a third wave
so
bam bam bam
not bad
not bad at all
not bad at all because look
okay it's actually good
all right
so as you guys saw uh usually on the
option market we have a concentration of
options around the money so around five
and then we have you know the shape
where it's decreasing but here look what
we have we have a 10 strike that is
massive it's the biggest amount of
options
so
so guys thank you for giving me that i
mean you know
i didn't see that and now that i see it
and that i see that we are potentially
in a third wave starting
uh i want to try that so there is no
guarantee but i might get in today stop
loss like i said around 380 something
like this
maybe even split 70 take some room and
play this third wave that might be
coming because if we start to go higher
strongly
we have the five strike the sixth strike
the seventh strike and most importantly
the 10th strike so we might quickly go
to the 12th
target i was just mentioning all right
so it's funny to see that we apply
different methods
and that we come up to the
same answers all right so this
could be like that and if we have a
third wave
then probably we will have a four and a
fifths coming so i like the stock guys
thank you for giving that to me let me
add it in my watch list
okay
so what did we say we said that we enter
at 490 stop loss at 390.
i came in 360
and target at 12. okay
bam
guys you're gonna see it coming on
discord today
so wkhs i like it and matt i like it
oh sorry i lost the webcam
okay guys i'm still here just my phone
has no more battery
uh okay but i'm gonna stop soon guys
okay
all right so i'm using my webcam so uh
it's not
as good as before but um
at least you can see me guys
all right uh it's uh it's been it's 4 15
p.m guys the sun is going so i think i'm
gonna take some time
uh i'm sorry i didn't do all of your
stocks
come to cali
i owe you for amc june squeeze hey bro
thank you so much for telling me that
it's really the reason why i'm doing
that man you know
you know i quit my job i i just quit
everything guys i wanted to be here on
this market with you take advantage of
all these opportunities and most
importantly pass the knowledge that i
have acquired you know during my career
it's it's no fun to work for those big
institutions it's so much fun guys to be
here with you uh help you and i'm very
happy that i do help you you know um
so thank you for telling me that it's
it's really it's really great
uh all right guys next year bro i'm
gonna do naked next time um
thank you so much guys uh don't forget
to smash that like button again guys
it's helping me a lot
um i'm gonna keep doing that i think
it's the best uh the best way for me to
you know share my um
my analysis with you to give you what
you really want to see
uh and it's very interactive it's only
my second life but i really enjoy doing
that
and
and i'm gonna keep doing that bonjour de
piupari hey brother
so thank you so much guys have a great
day have a great night have a great
morning i don't know where you are uh
thank you so much again uh for watching
these videos for um asking questions uh
a lot of love from from me and i see you
soon see you guys